hi guys and girls welcome back to my
channel I will go straight to the points
there are three things that I want to
talk to you about in this video first I
am back as you can see the second I
would like to make more videos and more
irregularly at least once a week and
third and maybe most important point of
this video is that I would like this
channel to be a more interactive that is
together with the normal videos that I'm
going to put and upload on youtube I
would also like to make some live events
where you can directly interact with me
and ask me questions on the go and I
will tackle them when I see them will
start obviously progressively and the
very first step that I would like to
undertake and this in this case is just
please if you can in the comment below
in the comment section below
just a right I would like Luka to talk
about and then the topic you you want me
to talk about you want me to to discuss
it should be obviously a topic that you
are interested in and you're probably
struggling with or that you want to know
more and and and improve on so as always
thanks for watching and let 2018 be a
fantastic year for a language learning